ce qui m'intéresse dans les
professionnels bien et professionnelle
quand ils ne sont pas trop venu
c'est-à-dire au c'est leur côté non
professionnels ce qui m'intéresse chez
belmondo c'est son côté c'est son côté
amateur par exemple et vous avez tous
les murs brigitte bardot les deux seuls
problèmes vraiment j'ai eu avec elle
c'était lui faire arriver à lui
permettre sa jupe en dessous du genou et
ça j'y suis absolument pas arriver alors
gelé la majeure partie du temps au viage
des milandes dans un peignoir ou bien au
contraire les cadres et ami ami poitrine
parce que ça pas question n'a pas voulu
elle tenait à ces petites jupes heures
et puis le faire baisser ce que sa
choucroute mains sales
son truc immense alors ça on l'a eue
s'était dit c'était difficile je vais
faire ma j'avais un jour je demandais
c'était un cas pris et puis lui dit
écoutez là c'est pas si longtemps que je
suis brigitte bardot alors et je vous
dis jean-luc c'est comme pour les juges
de ce chrono je tiens j'y touche pas tu
es nous
brit-brit enfin il ya eu confiance en
moi ça et puis il faut quand même c'est
trop grand ses programmes abc coûte
barré est ce que si par hasard
est ce que si ça ça faut au moins 15
centimètres votre truc au dessus du
franc est ce que sk cij est ce que si je
marche 15 mètres sur les mains enfin
disons parce que si je marche sur les
mains ce que chaque mètre que je marche
sur les mâles qui ont accepté de baisser
d'un centimètre votre coiffure
je n'accepte pas ce que c'est que vous
savez pas marcher sur les lignes alors à
10,8 alors devoir lâcher je fais ça
en effet un peu plus corps et ben la
charge avec la relève arrive mais
choucroute le vrai mystère du cinéma